this week Jewish people all over the
world are celebrating Passover or as I
call it the festival of missing writers
for a little light on material tonight
there's a reason even the Irish guys
took off today yeah Happy Passover
though I mean that today is the
beginning of the Jewish holiday of
Passover where families gather for a
meal and recall a story of ancient
grievances yeah
where is that's known in my family
Thanksgiving that's how we do it it's a
little bit about yeah sure we just sing
uh there's real stuff going on in the
world mm-hmm things are getting a little
tense with Russia do you know that yes
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is in
Russia but Russian President Vladimir
Putin won't meet with him
yeah Putin said sorry but I only meet
with members of the Trump administration
before the election that's my what seems
lighten this up a bit someone's come out
with a new smart bra did you hear about
this someone's come out with a new smart
Iommi's them up on new bra news look at
my website yeah someone's come out with
a new smart bra that vibrates to tell
women about posture and breathing yeah
it also sounds an alarm if bill o'reilly
walks in the room
this is the vibrating bra
why did you frown at me when I did this
because I thought that was the Bill
O'Reilly alarm and that seemed
counterproductive giving myself a an
exam right here Wow it's a good health
note good yeah there you go
because of these scandals The O'Reilly
Factor has lost two-thirds of its
advertisers in one week on the bright
side United Airlines is still with them
they said you'll have to drag us off
that show that was that
I'm good I wasn't looking for that in
the end I was looking to see where you
were and there you are yeah I was going
on other presidents in the news this
weekend Bill Clinton tweeted that he was
in Houston visiting former President
George HW Bush very nice yeah yeah right
sweet however he ended the tweet with
hashtag alibi hashtag alibi ever fooled
anybody
hashtag horndog yeah then we have some
astronomy fans here astronomers Wow now
you lie NOAA's primer goes yeah an
astronomer doesn't do that your planets
and yeah
let's go pound if you would talk planets
astronomers announced they have found a
second Red Spot on Jupiter second Red
Spot on Jupiter yeah pretty cool they
believe the new spot of his result of
hooking up with Neptune
so you applauded that Jim you're a
really nice crowd
true story I was backstage like I don't
know if we should even do that one
hooking up with Neptune and then you had
a quip you wanted to do about Uranus and
I was like hey I think when there's gold
dig for it yeah
you